[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le président bonjour
cette affiche ce sont des bons souvenirs
j'imagine oui ce sont des souvenirs tirs
ont été longtemps dans ma tête jusqu'au
moment où je suis devenu président car
il ya le temps heureux de la campagne et
puis le temps plus difficiles et pouvant
parfois douloureux de l'exercice d'un
mandat mais pour exercer un mandat faut
d'abord faire campagne et cette affiche
au nous l'avons fait assez tôt
d'ailleurs en 2011 fin 2011 puisque j'ai
été investi en octobre novembre 2011
pour un cliché qui va être affiché dans
toutes les communes de france qu'elle
est l'expression qu'on cherche à donner
à son visage quel sentiment vous
exprimer
là je voulais montrer un visage apaisé
serein
il y avait une élection le président
sortant n'avait pas les qualités en tout
cas celle là ça qu'on pouvait prêter un
président humain
calme posé donc je voulais faire le
contraire donc non je pensais que il
fallait être déjà dans le rôle parce
qu'être candidat si on veut gagner
l'élection c'est déjà être président et
vous vous trouvez bien vous sur la photo
on aimerait que je n'étais pas gêné par
la faute aux normes et parfois on n'aime
pas forcément se voir en photos dont je
me disais que si on n'aime pas se voir
au foot ou faut pas être candidat va
l'avoir beaucoup la faute au manque
justement vous disiez que la piste avait
été préparée avant vous même vous étiez
préparé à l'avant se souvient que vous
avez perdu une dizaine de kilos moi j'ai
lu vous étiez privée de vins de chocolat
de pain pour être candidat il faut se
priver de tous les plaisirs non il faut
se préparer d'abord intellectuellement
il ya un effort de programmes à
présenter de réflexion à ouvrir de
compréhension du monde et de ce point de
vue là on ne s'improvise pas candidat on
décide pas d'un jour au lendemain que ça
va être le choix de sa vie deuxièmement
il ya une préparation physique parce que
c'est aussi un marathon quand vous avez
perdu un petit peu de poids c'était
plutôt physiquement pour tenir là la
durée ou
parce que vous n'avez jamais fait cette
préparation si je puis dire pour moi
même et puis ça a eu un sens politique
beaucoup se sont dit les commentateurs
s'il a perdu du poids c'est qu'il veut
vraiment être candidats dont je voulais
vraiment perdre du poids ça donne aussi
le sentiment que quand on est candidat
il faut se transformer pour incarner
devenir le visage de la france ce qui
est non il faut se dire à quel moment
les citoyens vont se dire celui là où
celle là peut être le prochain président
surtout quand il ya un président sortant
qui a la légitimité c'est bien
compréhensible d'avoir
dirigé la france d'avoir pris des
décisions importantes
on ne change pas un président sortant
pour prendre un un amateur ou une
amatrice donc il fallait être capable de
d'incarner déjà la fonction pour que les
citoyens se disent oui c'est possible de
changer le changement c'est maintenant
mais en étant rassuré sur les capacités
et les qualités de la compétence de la
personne qui serait ainsi choisi vous
parlez du slogan il a marqué le
changement c'est maintenant un moment il
devait être en concurrence avec d'autres
slogans vous souvenez les autres slogans
avec elle vous avez hésité non ne vont
pas hésiter le changement c'est
maintenant
a pu être d'ailleurs compris de
multiples façons le changement c'est
maintenant ça voulait dire bah écoutez
vous avez l'occasion de changer par
votre vote là la gestion du pays le
titulaire de la fonction mais beaucoup
l'avait interprété sa veuve a été
parfois reproché comme le changement ça
va être tout de suite c'est vrai que je
vais être élu il y aura un très grand
changement ce qui veut dire que quand on
prend un slogan qui peut être bon dans
une campagne il vous poursuit ensuite
tous les candidats en fait preuve
propose les changements celui qui ne
peut pas proposer vraiment changement
c'est le président sortant cette fois on
a un inconvénient ou un avantage pour
vous cette année là alors je crois que
c'est toujours sur le thème du
changement ce qui explique que même les
présidents sortants disent qu'ils vont
changer dans la continuité
marqué du changement par rapport à ce
qu'ils ont fait aucun électeur ne veut
revivre ce qu'il a déjà connu il ya
toujours
un projet qui doit être présenté ce qui
explique d'ailleurs c'est très injuste
que les bilans ne sont pas toujours
porté en faveur du candidat sortant vous
avez déclaré votre candidature
publiquement des 31 mars 2011 c'était
plus d'un an avant l'élection mais on se
demande le moment où vous prenez la
décision en vous même avant d'en parler
aux autres ce que vous vous souvenez de
ce moment oui je me souviens j'avais
loupé le parti direction du parti
socialiste en 2008 et j'avais pris un an
pour réfléchir à ce que je voulais faire
devait faire et en
2009 j'ai commencé à me poser cette
question est-ce que je peux être le
candidat de la gauche et du parti
socialiste pour 2012 je n'étais pas
particulièrement le favori n'est pas
celui qui dans les sondages
apparaissez comme pouvant être le mieux
placé à ce jour là il y avait d'autres
noms notamment dominique strauss kahn ou
ségolène royal et en 2010 après donc
encore un an de travail programmatique
j'ai réuni mes amis j'ai dit écoutez
voilà vous avez fait une réunion
officielle pour dire mon parti a redit
combien la danse est très nombreux ils
étaient une dizaine et je dis bon ben
maintenant nous allons faire le tour de
france son parti à lorient nous sommes
partis à valence et puis après ils font
le tour de notre grand pays j'avais dit
si je suis réélu comme président du
conseil général puisque avait une
élection à ce moment là je déclarerais
ma candidature si je suis battu c'était
l'élection de pour être président du
conseil général pour être réélu bon bah
j'arrête un peut pas avoir la défiance
de son corps électoral aux plans local
et demander la confiance au plan
national est donc fort de cette nouvelle
investiture
départementale est lancé vous avez donc
annoncé d'abord votre candidature un an
avant audi solides piliers qui nous ont
accompagnés puis vous l'avez renoncé
publiquement à tulle en corrèze et on va
revoir quelques maugrée prendre c'est à
ce moment là si à tulle devant vous mes
amis j'ai décidé de présenter ma
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
à travers la primaire du parti
socialiste
vous l'avez dit c'est à tulle au siège
du conseil général vous veniez de
remporter des élections c'est votre fief
électoral l'accord et ça a pris 20 ans
pour vous pour conquérir ce département
vingt ans de bataille électorale est ce
que c'est être 20 ans d'entraînement
pour la campagne présidentielle
non la presse fois je me suis présenté
au suffrage en cause c'était en 1981
j'avais à peine 26 ans
nous
conclurons adversaire était jacques
chirac donc je savais que j'allais
affronter une personnalité très forte
qui était très bien installés en corrèze
je me suis pas dit je vais devenir
président de la république
trente ans après je me suis dit
simplement j'ai à faire mes preuves sur
un territoire qui n'est pas forcément le
plus facile et je vais essayer de faire
valoir les qualités de deux candidats
sans doute de gestionnaires sûrement
d'élu local départemental régional
national c'est parce que vous avez
franchi de nombreuses étapes en 20 ans
et donc je me disais qu'on devait
apprendre
la campagne électorale en tirer une
leçon qui doit être utile peut-être oui
c'est pour la corrèze s'était surtout
d'avoir un lien avec une population avec
un territoire d'avoir su créer la
confiance parfois l'affection l'amitié
qui m'était donnée d'être soutenue
portée mais les campagnes électorales
que j'ai menée je les ai mené au nom du
parti socialiste était premier
secrétaire du ps si vous n'êtes donc
nombreuses campagnes régionales
européennes législatives même
présidentielle puisque j'étais auprès
des choses pas en 2002 puis ensuite
auprès de séverine royan 2007 auch était
déjà habitué aux grands meetings aux
moments parfois difficiles au moment
contre un plus plus plus glorieux je
savais qu'elle était lé les différentes
étapes d'une campagne électorale je
l'avais connu deux victorieuses et
d'autres non donc j'étais préparée d'une
certaine façon parce que j'avais était
non seulement un élu d'un département
symbolique mais j'avais au surtout cette
expérience de premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
vous êtes candidat donc là depuis le 31
mars 2011 un mois et demi après c'était
le 14 mai un événement dont on se
souvient dominique strauss kahn est
arrêté à new york comment vous avez
appris cette nouvelle dans la nuit
je vois cette cette nouvelle arrivée je
doute même qu'elle soit
réelle tant elle paraît
non seulement inattendu mais mais
d'une brutalité terrible l'arrestation
d'un dirigeant important une
organisation internationale par ailleurs
potentiellement candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je me demande à ce pont
là si c'est bien confirmer s'il n'y a
pas eu là une exagération
ce n'est que le matin qu'on comprend que
j'imagine qu'elle est important et
qu'est ce que j'ai pensé au fond de moi
même assez tenerrdis depuis j'ai dit que
ça me privais en l'occurrence d'une
compétition que je voulais ouvert est
patrick c'était ça comme une bonne
nouvelle les éliminations à rival non
j'ai les prix pour d'abord sur le plan
personnel comme une catastrophe et une
humiliation
j'allais lire de voir que un homme
pouvait être atteint je le comprends
mais dans le cas d'une compétition qu'on
voit à travers sa principale est éliminé
on a le sentiment que ça pète dans
nouvelle le nom parce que j'avais
préparé cette confrontation avec
dominique strauss kahn fondations
politiques dans le même parti et j'en
étais privé et avec le risque d'ailleurs
qui s'est confirmée de beaucoup de
d'observateurs qui vont dit bah oui
finalement françois hollande a été
désigné parce que dominique strauss kahn
a sombré et donc je ne voulais pas ce
scénario vous vouliez le battre à la
régulière voulez oui je pense que j'y
serai parvenus les derniers sondages
d'ailleurs le laisser penser mitterrand
en 71 av au congrès d'epinay il a lâché
7 cette fameuse phrase en disant mon
véritable ennemi ce sont les puissances
de l'argent et vous savez ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que lors de votre
premier grand meeting au bourget vous
avez dit mon véritable adversaire n'a
pas de visage c'est le nom de la finance
là on a l'impression que vous avez
employé la méthode mitterrand pour être
élu moi je ne prends pas cette phrase
simplement sur l'argent nous sommes dans
une crise financière et de la
spéculation
il ya une fille danse qui s'est
déshonorée en laissant des économie
s'effondrer et donc je dois dire que
voilà ma responsabilité ça sera de 2 m
de côté cette finance là tout en
respectant celle qui
assure à l'économie réelle les moyens de
travailler et donc j'affirme que je vais
essayer de redresser la france d'après
en sorte que cette finance soit
repoussée ou bien tu veux rassembler son
camp dans une campagne présidentielle
j'ai l'impression qu'on est aussi besoin
de désigner un adversaire de montrer
l'ennemi du doigt pour rassembler son
temps c'est ce que vous feriez j'ai
préféré le faire d'ailleurs sur ce que
représentait cette puissance occulte
qu'on ne voit pas carrément la finance
les riches et qui n'a pas de visage
plutôt que de s'en prendre simplement à
mon adversaire dans l'élection
présidentielle j'ai pas de comptes à
régler à l'égard de nicolas sarkozy
cette phrase là avec la ferveur
remplissent de du meeting du bourget ce
qu'on a l'impression que vous étiez un
peu le chef de guerre c'est la bataille
électorale qui se lance on doit moyens
on doit donner le sentiment que la
direction donner le sens de ce que l'on
veut faire c'est pas simplement un effet
de tribune je savais que en prononçant
cette phrase est l'effet matin et moi
qui m'allait bien sûr suscité des
clameurs
soulevé un enthousiasme
est ce que je voulais c'était quand même
indiquer aux français que pas voilà il
ya une bataille électorale mais aussi
une bataille politique qui doit être
mené par le président lorsqu'il aura les
moyens d'agir cette phrase-là soulevé
l'enthousiasmé à faire dans ce cas pas
un risque en même temps deux on est soi
même porté par la ferveur de finir par
dire ce que les gens ont envie
d'entendre de leur faire des promesses
dont on n'est pas sûr qu'on pourra les
tenir simplement parce que vous êtes
emportés par cette ferveur non je
voulais justement ne pas faire des
promesses que je ne tiendrai pas j'avais
simplement cet objectif de lutter contre
le chômage et contre ce qu'il avait
produit en l'occurrence cette finance là
mais j'étais bien conscient que pour
port justement ma propre expérience que
les emballements de campagne se paye
ensuite c'est cher une fois que l'on
parvient au pouvoir je savais que
j'étais le favori de cette élection je
n'étais pas amené à faire de la
surenchère jeu j'avais la conviction que
j'allais gagner l'élection à partir de
là je devais justement maîtriser
les éventuels emportements parce que
j'aurais à agir quelques mois plus tard
mais j'avais aussi un a suscité cet
enthousiasme cette mobilisation parce
qu'une campagne électorale c'est une une
façon aussi de faire que 1 au moins la
moitié de la population française se
sentent qu'on veuille sa maman des
particuliers on souriait sans déshonoré
la l'autre moitié pourrait être grisé
vous pourriez être grisé quand vous êtes
sur scène ça doit de vertigineux d'avoir
tout un public qui vous soutient qu'ils
clament votre nom donc je m'intéressais
à cet effet griserie mais vous avez
répondu mais voilà ne vous inquiétez pas
il ya une différence je crois entre les
candidats qui sont là pour témoigner et
les candidats qui sont là pour gagner
moi j'étais là pour gagner je savais que
j'allais sans doute remporter cette
élection
peut-être aussi parce que donc
concurrent était d'être rejetée aussi
dans son dans son propre camp et parce
que moi j'étais appelé davantage par
l'union à ce moment là qu'ils se
forgeait autour de moi mais j'avais donc
cette responsabilité puisque je savais
que j'avais une forte probabilité de
l'emporter de ne pas voler c'est en pas
voler c'est justement emporté alors
salut fin février vous annoncez soudain
une taxe sur les très hauts revenus de
façon de 15% qui était pas dans vos 60
engagement donc pourquoi cette
modification soudaine du programme parce
qu'il se passe des événements dans une
campagne est toujours des informations
qui vont faire polémique qui vont faire
débat là il y avait eu la révélation de
rémunération très importante donnée un
un dirigeant d'entreprise qui avait
gagné par des stock options des millions
d'euros et ça avait soulevé la la
dérogation de savoir jusqu'à quel point
on pouvait tolérer que des rémunérations
soit à ce point excessive alors que le
pays vivait une période de crise donc je
cherchais comment répondre y avait aussi
le souci de reprendre l'initiative
d'où cette proposition d'aidé 75%
au-delà de 1 million d'euros par an
parent attention on a le sentiment cette
édition vous l'avez pris un petit peu
tout seul dans votre coin oui pas dire
que au lieu à un moment le candidat
écoute ses conseillers puis là c'est
votre instinct à qui je les prie avec
trois quatre conseillers je voulais
aussi créer un effet de surprise il
fallait que lorsque je viens vance cette
proposition qui devait d'ailleurs pour
un temps limité ce qui était le cas deux
ans elle soit suffisamment a aucune
vérité dans la presse avant l'annoncé il
y avait la fuite l'effet d'annoncé avait
beaucoup moins d'impact et donc il était
très important que ce soit qu'augmenter
comme étant une initiative venant de moi
même et que nul ne devait connaître
avant on parlait delà de la nécessité de
rassembler son camp plutôt sur le mode
guerrier mais vous avez rassembler le ps
pendant dix ans est ce que pour
rassembler votre secret c'est de ne
jamais être ni arrogant ni agressif oui
peut-être ne neige pas été suffisamment
agressif et et autoritaire lorsque la
désunion s'est installée mais c'est
l'union cette synthèse que j'avais
réussi à réaliser qui a permis la
victoire pas simplement la mienne
d'ailleurs c'était vrai de françois
mitterrand puis de lionel jospin c'est
pour que le parti socialiste est cette
capacité à à prétendre gouverner le pays
fallait qu'il rassemble des sensibilités
différentes et une fois que ces
sensibilités était dans le même parti
être capable de trouver une ligne
commune sans forcément tâter du
parlement sans forcément jouer les
autoritaires il s'agissait de de
façonner une ligne politique et c'est
quand llc
déstructuré cette ligne politique
côtelettes synthèse n'a plus été
possible
on a eu la situation qu'on a connu avec
les frondeurs j'ai montré une photo je
m'en a bon souvenir pour vous malgré
toutes ces belles dire que ça aurait dû
jouer en notre défaveur et puis vous
êtes resté complètement imperturbable ce
jour-là sa bouille inde où ses nerfs
d'acier se fait de ne jamais s'en porter
je me souviens très bien du moment
qui était celui là puisque c'était ce
que la fondation abbé-pierre réalise
d'ailleurs à chaque campagne
présidentielle réunis tous les candidats
et je devais signer un engagement sur un
somme de propositions en matière de
logement donc je m'installe
ce pupitre je me prépare à signer et une
personne vient derrière moi et jette
donc de la farine jusqu'à exactement
quel est le produit qui met des vaccins
je vois les caméras qui sont devant moi
je voie les photographes et je me dis je
vais continuer exactement ce que j'avais
prévu de faire signer comme si rien ne
s'était produit et c'est ça qui a été
relevé c'est à dire un sang-froid
ténacité rien ne doit empêcher d'aller
mon chemin 62 40 ans de carrière
politique qui nous aurons d'historique
ou c'est parce que vous êtes
imperturbable que vous avez été si loin
en politique non je pense que c'est
l'expérience sûrement ne pas se laisser
impressionner par un événement extérieur
et puis une forme de 200 francs que je
voulais que j'ai d'ailleurs par rapport
à des éleveurs des épreuves et il y en a
eu d'autres épreuves du stade façon
cette photo elle annonce peut-être
d'autres moments très difficiles très
douloureux du quinquennat ou face des
attentats face à des épreuves
internationales
j'ai tenu il ya une qualité que par ce
nouveau contexte c'est l'humour je me
demandais si pour vous c'était plutôt un
moyen de défense au plus tôt une arme un
les deux je pense que du mot est une
façon d'ouvrir les esprits c'est à dire
de susciter de le sourire de susciter
aussi un moment
l'amusement sur une situation y compris
sur soi même et c'est aussi une façon de
d'être encore plus sérieux quand on sort
de l'humour par l'humour vous vous
ouvrez l'esprit ensuite vous pouvez
faire passer l'idée j'ai l'impression
que c'est une forme de pudeur vous avez
gagné le grand prix de l'humour de mini
celle qui voit la france qui a été
récompensée c'est donc à la fin de votre
mandat de dommages j'étais à deux doigts
du moment les français les mémés cessé
de la céda pudeur parce que c'est un peu
triste oui je vous dis les mots ça
commence par s'exercer pour soi même et
lebouc parfois être joyeux parfois plus
de statut pour vous j'ai l'impression
que c'est une forme de pudeur comme il
ya des deux je pense que l'humour est
une arme d'armes défensives pour
effectivement se mettre en en résistance
par rapport à l'extérieur et puis aussi
offensive et rien n'est pire que une
phrase lancée dans un débat et qui va
faire beaucoup plus quel discour ya un
moment qui a été très dur pour votre
pudeur pendant la campagne c'est quand
votre vie privée a été mis sur la place
publique tant sa part à ce dans tous les
journaux et parce que là vous avez
réussi à faire preuve d'humour pour vous
défendre de south était trop violent
donc il faut savoir quand on se présente
à l'élection présentielle avec de fortes
chances de l'emporter que tout un tout
va être
vérifié regarder
l'espionné
révélé donc voilà c'est très dur pour la
vie ou saviez à l'avant ce que votre vie
privée allait être mise à rude épreuve
où elle avait déjà été avant et donc
qu'elle a été pendant la campagne il a
été encore davantage président mais je
dois dire que même si c'est très très
révoltant parfois par rapport aux
méthodes utilisées
insupportable même quand on voit que
c'est aussi une façon de gagner de
l'argent pour une certaine presse ou
pour certaines agences mais c'est aussi
le prix à payer hélas
il y as est aujourd'hui ce voyeurisme
qu'il y ait doit surtout pas être
précédée par un exhibitionniste parce
que ce que l'on a le voyeurisme et est
récompensé par ailleurs si on ne veut
pas être justement dans cette situation
là il faut pas se présenter à l'élection
ça vous nous l'avez dit dès le départ
vous avez franchi toutes les épreuves
vous êtes arrivé au premier tour en tête
tous les sondages vous donnent vainqueur
au second tour donc à ce moment là vous
êtes certain de gagner j'imagine
certains n'ont
pas ce qu'il peut toujours se produire
pendant quinze jours ça dure encore
quinze jours entre le premier tour et le
second tour des événements faut être à
la fois attentif vigilant
sur ses gardes
à certaines occasions et toujours prêt à
éventuellement de prendre une initiative
et puis avec le débat de long à tour le
débat alors le fameux débat non non non
moi j'étais comme 18 en français ça a
duré 3 minutes 20 mois président moi
président 16 fois l'iba là il en train
de gagner la campagne vous avez
sentiment quand vous parliez vous étiez
en train de remporter la victoire à la
fin oui la fin de de la tirade si je
vous dis oui oui parce que je je savais
que dans tout grand débat présidentiel
il y avait que quelques minutes qui
était retenue est celle là et elle est
plus forte donc je n'avais pas de doute
sur ce qui serait retenu de cet
affrontement enfin ce qui me frappe
c'est que ça a été improvisée donc un
moment de crucial de la campagne n'est
pas préparé et il paraît décisif
heureusement qu'il y a quand même de
l'improvisation
heureusement qu'il y à de l'inattendu de
la surprise
il y avait dans cette phrase bien sûr
des des
démos que j'avais déjà utilisé dans des
meetings mais je n'avais jamais pensé
que je ferai une séquence aussi longue
et elle mais fournit parce que de la
journaliste qui m'interroge je me pose
la question vous président ce qui me
permet de dire moi président est mal
d'argent aujourd'hui tout le monde se
présente en disant moi président alors
attention la grande question celle à
laquelle seulement trois personnes en
france peuvent répondre aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand on est élu
président de la république
d'abord il n'ya pas une information qui
vous est donnée officiellement vous
n'apprenez pas par
une autorité que vous êtes président de
la république là il faudra attendre le
conseil constitutionnel quelques
quelques jours après donc j'apprends que
je suis président parce que je reçois
des coups de téléphone d'instituts de
sondage qui me confirme que selon leurs
estimations
je gagnerai 52 48 à peu près gêné lui
reçu comme information que celles qui
m'ont été donnés par des instituts de
sondage avouez que ce n'est pas très bas
on hésite à exploser de joie j'imagine
les émouvants
ensuite
je nicolas sarkozy eut l'élégance de
m'appeler m'a dit voilà avant 20 heures
avant 20 heures
vous êtes le prochain président et nous
aurons à régler les problèmes de
transmission de nos responsabilités et
lors comment fait-on pour être sûr que
c'est bien vrai on se pince on fait
comme tous les français on s'assoit dans
un fauteuil on attend le journal de 20h
et on se dit si mon visage apparaît à 21
c'est que je suis le président pourquoi
on se dit on se dit ça je me suis dit ça
non pas parce que j'avais un doute sur
le fait que j'étais élu je le savais
mais parce que ce qui est important ce
n'est pas de le savoir soi même c'est
que tous les français le sachent en même
temps c'est en ce sens que le 20 heures
sur les chaînes de télévision ou le
visage du président ou de la présidente
va apparaître et bien et le moment
décisif quand vous êtes avec le candidat
avec tous les français conscients que il
n'y a qu'un seul président c'est vous
vous avez donc à ce moment là ou plutôt
le sentiment d'avoir ddl qui vous
pousser dans le dos avec la victoire au
contraire un poids énorme qui vous
tombez sur les épaules
1dl non
du bonheur de la fierté oui de la
conscience et de la lucidité encore
davantage je savais qu'on était dans une
situation extrêmement difficile
et j'ai eu le soir même à 20h30 des
échanges téléphoniques avec par un
combat avec eux ok là merkel et donc
j'étais déjà dans dans la la prise en
compte de la réalité la réalité elle
elle vient vite vous rappeler que on n'a
pas le temps de s'en réjouir vous êtes
sans doute président vous avez vécu
une période extrêmement fort intense
mais vous allez être devant dès des
responsabilités que vous ne pourrez pas
écartée donc le moment de bonheur de mes
bras joie fait extrêmement court même
s'il est au säntis intérieurement mais
le moment où vous dites que qu'est ce
qui m'attend lui il va durer les grands
sportifs pros dans le food il rêve de
gagner le ballon d'or mais dès qu'ils
ont 4 5 ans vous ce que vous rêviez de
devenir président quand vous étiez
enfant je m'intéressais déjà la
politique confond enfin quand j'ai eu
l'âge de comprendre ce qui se passait
sur un écran de télévision et c'était la
première élection présidentielle
1965 je me suis pas dit voilà je vais
être là quelques années ou décennies
plus tard mais j'étais déjà passionné
par ce que représentait la politique au
sens où ça déterminer non seulement des
vies
personnelles mais médée vie commune
c'est à dire un destin collectif
je me suis engagé ensuite assez tôt en
politique j'aurais pu ne pas devenir
président ma vie n'aurait pas été pour
autant
disons 1 un échec serait pas ni bas
puisque je suis pas devenu président ça
n'avait pas de sens si ma vie c'était de
faire un choix un engagement au service
des autres et celui là il n'est pas
encore achevé ce choix la boîte vocation
précoce devez vous en souvenir elle a
été évoquée par votre mère un jour elle
était invitée chez michel drucker elle
vu françois il était il voulait devenir
président depuis tout petit moi je les
encourage et donc ont écouté ça on se
disait c'est peut-être devenu président
pour faire plaisir à sa mère hélas que
je suis devenu président ma mère n'était
plus là mais c'est vrai qu'elle elle m'a
toujours
encouragé porte et
éclairé quelquefois donc je sais ce que
je dois à mes parents ça a été un moteur
même en 2012 c'est vrai j'ai pensé à
elle mon père était encore vivant
lui n'était pas de forcer mans 2-2 des
mêmes idées que celles que je pouvais
moi même défendre mais il était sans
doute assez fier de ce que j'avais pu
réaliser je les appelais au téléphone
avant 20 heures pour le prévenir et il
m'a dit ah bah voilà je te plains
merci beaucoup monsieur résidents
[Musique]